foreign
you're with me
that's true take it slow
your drugs are still wearing off
yeah it was just the fireflies and then
yeah we're running some tests on you
and some others
turns out there's a whole lot more like
you
know people that are immune
dozens of them
the doctors they couldn't make any of it
work
they've actually said
I know it's very intrusive box they've
stopped looking for a cure
the people hurt
yes
she knows she doesn't have to ask she
knows oh yeah clearly
she was the first to die
and then it was Tess
that's not on you I know but sometimes
please don't work out the way we hope
it's got like a whisk you don't feel
like
like you've come to an end
you don't know what to do next
but if you just keep going
you find something new to fight for
maybe that's not what you're doing to me
swear to me that everything you said
about the fireflies is true
I swear
wow building this Foundation already not
on trust
just happened so easily so easily he he
did Eli did protect her
I'm not saying that's a great thing
okay welcome back to New rockstars the
finale of The Last of Us season one is
finally yeah so nine look for the light
what a wild ride this season has been
and this episode is no exception this is
the break room Our Daily Show that keeps
you updated on all the nerdy news that
you need to know and today we're talking
about all season one finale of The Last
of Us so wipe away those tiers and save
your questions about morality and ethics
for the end as we dive into this episode
I'm Jessica Clemens not Carl's Winslow I
know you think I am I am not we'll get
into the outfits in a little bit we'll
explain that hours from now yes well I'm
not going to win as well I'll tell you
that much or Steve Harvey who are you
minute I'm Jessica Clements Jessica
Clemens and with me today is Brandon
Barrick oh hello and Anna vanston I need
the battery test oh a single battery
[Applause]
power's a car right here it's true it's
true
uh well we can't wait to dive into this
episode and talk more about it in the
whole season in general but we want to
remind you to check out nerd riot.shop
where you can still grab the Last of Us
inspired shirt lost in the darkness and
check out the link in this video's
description where you can also grab this
jacket from huckberry it's the same
jacket that Joel wears on the show we're
not the exact same one he's got his own
version but huckberry sells this jacket
uh so if you wanna if you wanna dress
like Joe if you want to get that Joel
fit for the summer get this nice warm
jacket from huckberry check out the link
in the show's uh description to check
that out for yourself now as a reminder
as we go through the first part of this
episode today we're gonna be as spoiler
free as possible we're not going to talk
about uh uh things from the video game
that weren't in the show or talk about
part two of the video game or where the
stories goes we're just gonna stick
about what we saw on the show uh this
first season we recommend if you haven't
played the games avoid reading the
comments and if you're in the comments
I'll be spoiling everything okay uh
there's a lot of stuff set up for season
two throughout this series uh but we'll
we'll have a big warning before we get
into all that talk at the end of this
episode so for now you're safe you're
safe with us it was Raiders okay don't
worry about it don't ask questions this
episode opens on a pregnant Ellie's mom
nope that's right uh long time Last of
Us fans will recognize that Anna is
played by Ashley Johnson the voice actor
of Valley from the games also from
critical role also from a bigger part in
the First Avengers movie but she's still
featured in the film she makes her way
to a two-story Farmhouse once again
hearing the howl of an infected in the
distance we've had so little infected
last few episodes yeah uh you almost
forget that they're still out there uh
but we open on one this time and it's
pretty harrowing yes Anna enters the
house and calls out for the rest of the
fireflies but no one is there
[Music]
buddy oh God this is stress inducing as
the sound of the infected grows closer
she manages to make her way up the
stairs but her water breaks and if
you're an idiot like me you were like
what is that
Anna goes into what looks like a child's
bedroom and barricades the door with a
chair between her pain breathing we hear
the sound of something entering the
house
she pulls out a familiar switch play for
protection
um call back the infected burst through
that door and scrambles towards Anna
this is probably one of the top 10 worst
things that happen while giving birth
yeah maybe number one because you're not
expecting this I mean honestly she gave
she actually popped the thing out with
such ease that I'm like well I was like
considering
the adrenaline I was like maybe someone
needs to pop under the bed and scare you
and then it shoots out if you or your
partner you're gonna be having a child
soon hire someone to burst into the room
right as right as the baby's coming out
it'll make the baby coming out seem much
wide baby I'm gonna kill you she
it
it pounces on Anna like
you're trapped between a murderous
cordycep and a wall yeah honey and
you're giving birth
she struggles to re honestly worse than
House of the Dragon where's the house of
the dragon that was some brittle
birthday yes I don't know she struggles
to reach her knife while trying to avoid
getting bit she finally grabs and kills
the infected stabbing it multiple times
that's right but during the scuffle and
it has given birth to Ellie
needs a water birth I mean I cried I
this was just that little baby was so
adorable can't wait to have three uh she
takes a second and all this new life uh
and then looks at her thigh to see that
she was bitten by the infected during
the struggle uh and she quickly realizes
that the baby is still attached via the
umbilical cord which she cuts quickly
ties it off picks up the baby and it
Comforts Ellie as she lets out another
series of cries and Anna says you
[__] Talent Melly just so good I'm
gonna cry just thinking about it it's
just beautiful just like so good and
knowing everywhere that Ellie's bed
since then it's just like oh
[Music]
just get ready
um Marlene and a few other firefights
finally arrive I was like she's like
sorry we're late yeah sorry stuff you're
sorry I'm not gonna be that person but
I'm pregnant not anymore I'm not
pregnant Marlene should have been there
already she leads them through the back
of the house and see the smash window
that the infected entered through and
make their way up the stairs we hear
Anna softly singing ahas the sun always
shines on TV Ellie's love for aha is in
her blood and I love it her tape is
probably her mom's tape don't don't
forget
you're gonna start crying again I know I
know Marlene calls out to her and
there's no answer Marley makes her way
to the bedroom and solely pushes open
the door her flashlight revealing the
Dead Infected as well as Anna holding
baby Ellie Anna removes the knife that
she's holding up against her neck we see
a small Mark enough to draw blood but
not enough to kill her she was likely
ready to kill herself which again top 10
worst things like having to stab
yourself today knowing that you're
turning and you'd be like I gotta save
this baby oh my God and not knowing when
they're coming back right right yeah
like or if you're ever coming there
she's so lucky they have Marlene is so
lucky she held out that long like I was
like it's dark now I would have thrown
myself out there okay either way we see
the infection spreading on her thigh
Anna reassures Marlene that it's not her
fault while Marlene tries to explain
that they were delayed getting out of
the qz place in this house near Boston
but Anna is all business saying Ellie
needs to be fed she doesn't want to
nurse her because
she's infected which is kind of how
how are they going to feed
how are they going to be absolutely like
a formula right there's probably formula
there are potentially like other women
who are also have given birth recently
and are able to give milk you probably
make so much money in the qz if you're a
woman that's breastfeeding and you have
milk to supply other people yeah holy oh
that's what I'm gonna do okay
my new job become pregnant 24 7.
importantly Anna stresses stop this is a
sad part okay importantly Anna stresses
to Marlene does she cut the umbilical
cord before she was bit which is a damn
old face it's a good lie though she had
two she had to I mean we do know she was
bitten allegra and that chart was like
we know that's multiple hours double
digit hours for the infection to get
kind of that far
right but it's a lot closer to the
stomach but it's got to go through the
bloodstream and then get into the
digestive stream I don't know I don't
know baby science folks uh but I I think
there's no baby scientists I know baby
scientist but I think this calculator
risk paid off because she's got that
immunity yeah that's true oh you're
keeping noted she has Marlene to take
her to Boston and to find someone to
raise her and I guess Marley decided the
school for fascist was truly the best
option with Ellie in her hands Marlene
refuses to kill Anna she begs screaming
after Marlene as she leaves the room and
this scene tore me apart I mean
oh God I couldn't oh my God I wish I
could have fast forward through this but
I have to watch this for you guys
Marlene passes baby Ellie off to one of
the other fireflies and then returns in
total darkness literally stomping down
the hallway to quickly shoot Anna The
Gunshot causes Ellie to cry and Marlene
returns to hold and comfort her I was so
pissed because she handed off Ellie and
she was like something like hold her
with bow pants or a supporter head or
something and she goes back and this
guy's just like and he's just like cover
cover her ears that's what it was that
is my move this guy I hope he got
reprimanded by the fireflies
and let this child hear her mother get
killed that and then I was like okay the
baby like in a quiet place I'm like okay
the baby's gonna sound off and alert
other courtesies right so I was like
please you guys keep this in mind
someone teaches men how to raise a child
okay it's modern day folks we got a
modern day Ellie who's lost and thought
while sitting in the back of a pickup
truck on the highway towards Salt Lake
City she's just coming off the events of
David but it's Weighing on her right
Joel tries to get her attention after
Scavenging he found a can of Chef
Boyardee her favorite and then came back
on he wants to show her he's like
getting excited daddy so happy but she
is not having it she's remaining distant
and not even the fact that Joel offers
the teacher how to play guitar can
really hold her attention though this is
like the most was probably honest like
uh dad child moment when you when your
father tries to teach you something that
they're passionate about you're like I
don't care loser okay Boomer take your
guitar somewhere else buddy that
relatable moment where your daughter is
PTSD and he's disassociated very
relatable your daughter just killed
someone you're trying to have fun and
she can't get over it let's grow up
already like that sometimes wow this is
the warmest we've seen Joel since the
first episode is the most attached we've
ever seen Joey who's Ellie who's one of
our most empathetic characters she's
just like I mean she's shut she's 14
years old this is a lot even in uh a
post-apocalyptic world that's all she's
known this is a lot yeah Ellie
identifies the classic Joel plan of
finding a skyscraper to go up and look
around to get their bearings and the two
make their way up to a decrepit building
in Salt Lake City Joel spies a ladder
through a hole in the floor above them
this is a very video gaming moment uh
when looking to give Ali a boost we see
her again zoning out Joel tries to check
with her uh saying she seems extra quiet
today after Ellie apologizes Joel
doesn't press the point we get a classic
gay moment as he boosts Ellie to the
next floor she starts to lower the
ladder but something catches her
attention causing her to drop the ladder
on Joel which again I'm like Ellie
stop this
yeah I was happy to get a little even a
little bit of emotion out of her and
this is like the first bit we get is her
excitement here
um he climbs up the ladder and is barely
able to keep his eyes on her as she runs
ahead urging him to follow and after a
lot of running which certainly must have
been a killer on Joel's knees he climbs
a final flight of stairs to give us one
of the most iconic images from the game
the giraffe Wow
real giraffe so
no I think okay hold on hold on hold on
I'm gonna make just a little argument I
think it might be maybe a mixture of
Seasons yeah there's some CGI I mean of
course of course but I think maybe they
there was rumors that they went to a zoo
eating the plant out of the hand you
can't tell me that CG
I think it's maybe a mixture of a real
giraffeine the background of it was uh
in the nicest way possible really bad
because I remember walking at the but it
blended with the giraffe's head and
that's right
okay but keep going regardless that
moment is such a good moment because I
feel like to me the giraffe symbolizes
like uh a life worth living for Ellie
it's the first time she snaps out of
this disassociation and PTSD
um trauma and uh is like reminded why
she should go she gets excited for life
again and what I extra love about this
moment in the show is that while Ellie
is so focused on the giraffe and what is
worth fighting for to her Joel the
entire time is looking at Ellie which is
what is that's what's worth fighting for
for him and it's this beautiful moment
where they're both like just reminded of
why they are still you think Joel's
thinking like that's a lot of meat on
the giraffe
no that's the thing they put there's a
polar bear in the California zoo right
he's probably laughed he was like I'm
out of here no you think he's trying I'm
colder weather hey I'm gonna travel
probably around David's Village oh my
God and they probably ate it no they
prefer people did things to it keep
going
so in a call back to the time in Boston
the two repeat their exchange while
looking at the Boston skyline
so
is it everything you hoped for
guided suction down
you can't deny that view
is it everything you hoped for
jury's still out
but man you can't deny that for you it's
all like kind of smiles and juggles it
then that's so sweet uh Joel tries to
level with Ellie he tells her that there
may be something bad out there using
that as an out to say that they don't
have to find the hospital he's really
slow playing this this totally reminds
me of when uh they were kind of meeting
up with Tommy and Jackson and you could
see Ellie being like I don't like this
I'm losing this Dynamic I'm gonna lose
Joel to this new thing Joel's feeling
like I'm gonna lose Ellie to whatever
this new thing is this was the whole end
goal and now we're here the months have
passed but I don't want it to go away I
don't want to leave the second guessing
is real Ellie pushes back saying after
everything they've done it can't be for
nothing and this is so like Joel where
like a strong Confident Woman tells him
the business and he takes it like we saw
this with Tess we're like he didn't want
to leave tests and Tess is like you save
this girl you get her you get her to
Colorado you do it has to be done and
he's like you got it boss I think
Jewelers at least on this yeah at least
done this before to him where she takes
a firm hand with him I mean this this
was him wrapped up in the blanket ready
to die she gives him a knife he says you
gotta kill these guys I gotta go okay
and he does it so right here like when
he's ready to back out and he's hoping
Ellie will say what you know what you're
right we don't got to be here let's go
she's like no we gotta do this it's
Gotta mean something and not only he
takes that not only does she say after
everything we've done she then follows
it with after everything I've been
through and he can't argue with that
I mean yeah after what he told Tommy
he's like I made her she had to kill guy
because of me well even things that
weren't
David think mostly I feel like that's
really
really why he takes responsibility
he's like it's my fault I got a baseball
bat shoved in my abdomen and you had to
deal with that I should have been that I
should have been better uh back on the
ground the two make their way through an
abandoned Army Medical Camp it prompts
Joel to open up about his past uh as he
had been in one of those in the early
days of the outbreak because of uh the
wound weaves that was called out on his
ear earlier you know someone he said he
was like shot at it and missed uh Ellie
mentions that guy who shot Adam and
missed right and Joel reveals that the
man who shot and missed was in fact Joel
himself oh boy uh Joel tried to unalive
himself in the early days of the
pandemic uh Joel indulges Ellie in some
shitty puns uh from no pun intended
volume two uh but behind them a man's
definitely tosses the flashbang and they
get knocked to the ground this guy was
camping around the corner folks classic
Call of Duty technique it was such a
game move but then I was also like
why did you throw that I mean they don't
know they don't want to kill them but it
was just so cartoony to be like right
and then if you if you call out and
you're like hey hey you there they could
turn around and start black
hey yo welcome to Salt Lake City
uh have you heard of uh The Book of
Mormon um so one of them grabs Ellie and
she shouts for Joel who swiftly knocked
out with the butt of a gun another
classic video game moment to get you
from one section to another you get
knocked out you wake up somewhere else
there you go Joel comes to Lane in a
hospital bed she can spray painted
Firefly logos as his vision comes back
into focus and who is there to greet him
but Marlene
welcome home Joe we haven't seen in a
very long time I've seen her since
episode one yeah like Tess I was like
we're only going to get them for so
little time whatever Joel immediately
asked where Ellie is Marlene tells him
that she's safe but being prepped for
surgery Marlene slowly explains that
their doctor believes that the cordyceps
has grown with Ellie since birth
producing a chemical messenger that
makes normal cordyceps think he she's
also a cordyceps thus making her immune
whoa insane wow the plan to make the
Cure the doctor is going to remove the
cordyceps from her multiply the cells in
the lab and produce the chemical
Messengers this could be the Cure
they've been searching for this entire
time but Joel knows cordyceps grows in
the brain that's right and Marlene knows
this too so this surgery will kill Ellie
I wonder if these like cordyceps
Messengers in her brain is maybe what
makes Ellie more interested in violence
than most
maybe just adds a little flavor of oh
interesting environment that's a very
interesting uh uh maybe Joel has a
cordycep then uh because Joel has been
standing on my face yes yes there are
there are parasites that act like that
uh one uh notably the one for the ants
one that goes through like cats and rats
basically uh if you're a pregnant woman
you're not supposed to have the kids
toxic plasmosis it gets into a rat and
makes the rat unafraid of cats so the
rat gets near a cat the cat eats the rat
and now the toxic plasmosis is in the
cat where it wants to be comes out in
the feces Radix the feces cycle
continues so you're telling me if I eat
feces I won't be afraid of cats anymore
well what can happen is this could get
into your brain Jessica and it can start
to alter your personality and there are
theories that like toxic plasmosis and
humans can make them more violent or
tend to be a little more wild or change
how they process we all are currently
affected by parasites viruses and
bacteria living in our bodies
multiplying affecting the way we reacted
if co-evolved with us for millions of
years folks and also Harkens back to
what we're talking about last week is
she could she infect someone if if it's
alive in her still and it's just not
infecting her body could she give it to
someone else you should try to bite
someone she should just bite an [__]
before it happens we'll bite someone who
is an [__] bite them on their [__]
I'll bite the ass I'll take one for the
team Marlene tells Joel that Ellie
wasn't informed because why would they
tell him why would they ask you why
would you why would you ask yeah so
she'll have no fear and there won't be
any pain Joel demands will be taken to
her and is decked by a guard oh buddy
Marlene tells her guards to walk him out
to the highway with his pack to give him
Ellie's knife and that if he tries
anything to shoot him this is classic
James Bond evil bad guy Behavior should
have just killed him right then Marlene
that was your first mistake two guards
Usher Joel out of the hospital room
R.I.P guys they walk him down the
decrepit Hospital hallway this guy has
got to be one of the dumbest guys in the
whole show Marlene should have warned
them that I mean she knows what he's
capable of right and I thought I thought
about that when the guy was like keep
walking yes I was like you're kind of
afraid of this this guy's like kind of
slowing down he's gonna pull something
on you like be careful as they lead him
down the stairwell Joel spins around
punching a guard in the face Joel grabs
his gun and shoots both of them hitting
the guard who was ordering him around in
the leg Joel asks him where Ellie is to
which the guard says [__] you that's
Ellie's line you can't yeah he says that
to me so Joe kills him he doesn't have
time for this BS and we hear cries of
alarms come out over the dead guards
radio Joel Richie's Ellie's knife off
one of their bodies and heads back into
the hospital Jesus in an incredible
action montage and I love this I watched
this and I watched John Wick and I said
what's the difference what's the damn
difference Joel blasts his way back to
the hospital murdering the fireflies
left and right and Cold Blood we and we
get one more giraffe illusion I don't
know if y'all saw this he's going to
have a pediatric uh hallway and there
are little animals all over the
wallpaper right we see some monkeys we
see a little hippo but there is a little
blurry giraffe oh okay that reminded me
too of like when they find the the
little Hideout underneath Kansas City
where they've like kind of painted the
wall so like joyous and happy but this
is an evil doctor place right as he's
making his way through this pediatric
surgery Wing right the music is like a
darker take on the Show's theme it's
giving us like evil it's giving us
Menace is Joel the bad guy here have the
tables turned in a way we're not
comfortable with I don't know uh so he
makes his way into the operating room
and he sees a doctor and two nurses
hovering over Ellie who was sedated in a
hospital gown making his way inside Joel
watches them remove the oxygen mask from
her he surprises the group telling them
to unhook her I thought it was really
weird they didn't have a guard for this
room but that's totally fine uh the
doctor steps forward grabbing a surgical
tool he says he won't let go take her
brave move my guy uh yeah what you gonna
do you said you would do no harm and
you're about to harm Joel but I see your
point Joel doesn't waste a second
doesn't even hear him out shoots him
causing the nurses to scream this time
they listen when he asks him to unhooker
a free Ellie from the medical apparatus
and banish her arm Joel keeps the gun
trained on the nurses telling them to
turn around which they do he lifts Ellie
out of the bed as he walks away with her
arms we get a close-up of the doctor
that Joel's shot who's bleeding from The
Gunshot in his head and as he's carrying
her away I feel like there's a really
good setup shot as he's looking down
that Echoes his moment with Sarah
he makes it down uh to to the parking
garage and he walks towards a car with a
battery attached to it getting charged
up from around the corner we hear
Marlene's voice saying you can't keep
her safe forever Marlene asked what he
thinks Ellie would choose that she would
probably want to do what's right and
that Joel knows that we cut to a tired
looking Joel driving down a country road
for a second we're with him until we
hear a tiny exhale in the rear view
mirror we see Ellie still in the
hospital scrubs laying in the backseat
he didn't leave her behind he took her
with him of course so Comforts her as
she comes to her senses he tells her the
drugs are wearing off and it shows with
Ali slow to come too simulate the last
thing she remembers just being with the
fireflies she asks what drugs becoming
clear that she didn't know that she
would be operated on she was like slip
something uh without her knowledge Joel
musters himself up for the hard
conversation but he does not have
because he lies and he tells her they
were running tests on her and dozens of
other immune people exist but the
doctors couldn't make any of it work and
they've stopped looking for a cure this
is all great BS to give Ellie uh on
screen we see Marlene lower her gun and
approach the two of them and then she
gets shot by jaw I don't know how he
managed to sneak
but he did a great job
good job body strength he has really
shown it this whole season one hand
lifting her little cat and then just go
I mean it's like the sneak attack they
did in it uh in Django and Shane when he
had the gun come out of the sleeve they
just like lifted the little leg oh yeah
yeah uh so Ellie keeps asking questions
Joel keeps the lies going saying that
Raiders attacked the hospital they have
time to grab her clothes they barely
escaped I think Ellie's a she's already
suspicious about what's going on she
asked if people are hurt to which Joel
takes a second before finally replying
yes his first honest answer when asked
if Marlene is okay Joel simply says I'm
taking you home so he doesn't really
give an answer there Ellie accepting
this explanation or not turns away from
Joel in the back seat with Joel not
giving an answer
I mean that's a very non-answer answer
from Joel
and Dad's lie yeah sorry Dad sorry sorry
dads sorry dads uh through all of this
we see what's actually played out
happening in Joel's mind he can't shake
it he's clearly very shook he's the one
who shot Marlene um
she can't shake it can't shake folks uh
he shoots my Lane lays alley in the
backseat of the car uh before he gets in
the driver's seat he hears Marlene
coughing trying to pick herself up she
begs for her life but Joel said that
she'd only come after Ellie and she
probably would he shoots Marlene one
final time it'd be like that we get a
travel Montage the car traveling look
here my daughter
the same thing that's right
my baby we get a travel Montage the car
traveling through the winter Midwestern
landscape arriving in Wyoming we get a
close-up of La looking at her infection
and Joel assesses that the car is broken
down
it was it was sputtering smoke and
everything yeah I think the car broke
down I was like
you did I was like yeah me not a car
person can tell that he tells Ellie that
it's only about five hour hike to
Jackson five hours it's a throwback
Mode episode three four whenever they're
in the woods yeah and he's like five
hour hike she says
and he goes get it and I'm like till I
get it I'm here with you we've all been
there too like we can see Ellie's
perspective like when you've had a rough
confrontation with your parents and
they're just trying to move past it and
you're like yeah we can move she also
like just came to and she's like I'm
confused I'm still disoriented you're
gonna make me walk well and she hates
the idea of people being killed because
of her
and she doesn't know this full
circumstances but she knows that people
died because of her yeah or well she
thinks
um
so yeah if she never existed Joel would
have never killed all those people I
guess as the two make the height Joel
tells her about Sarah he recalls her
fondly the most comfortable we've seen
him be when talking about her period
Joel says that he thinks Sarah and Ellie
would be friends because she's funny and
also adds that Sarah's a little more
preppy
she's a little girly yeah yeah uh the
two get to the hill overlooking Jackson
Ellie tells Joel that she had to kill
Riley after she got bit and she still
holds that guilt guilt that seemingly
would have been a race if she could have
been the key to that cure to Ellie this
was the first person to die on her
journey and she starts recalling
everyone else that has died so far like
Tess and Sam and just added to a list of
people she feels guilty for for dying
and it wasn't her fault it was her fault
technically was the first person yeah
technically her mom
does yeah she knows her mama's [__] she
didn't know much about her mother and
she asked if Marlene was her mother so
she had no idea if her mother was alive
or dead okay oh [__] okay yeah noted uh
Joel cuts are off saying it's not on her
saying things don't always work out he
relates her experience to his how it can
feel like you can come to an end and not
know what comes next but if you keep
fighting you'll find something to fight
for Ellie Cuts him off she asked him to
swear to her that everything he said
about the fireflies was true and after a
second he says I swear oh
period La takes this in mulling it over
she looks back at Joel and says okay
cut to the credits down oh my goodness
he said and then it's one thing to be
like yes or no to be like I swear you
can't even act like you vaguely said
something I mean uh okay well let's just
get into it all right now okay there's
two parts to my first question here did
Joel make the right choice and do you
think Ellie believes the LIE who wants
to answer first if Joel I'll say short
I'll say short and then we can get in
there yeah give me your short did girl
make the right choice
okay what's your short answer Anna did
y'all make the right choice
no
and I want my short answer is the short
answer yeah
the right choice no but
but there's a long answer too there's a
long time
uh yeah no so I'm I'm gonna be making a
longer video on this that dives into the
psychology and all this good stuff but
I'm gonna talk it's just my opinion
right now um I my longer more elaborate
answer is that from an outside
perspective there is not really a way
that you can reason in a way like it's
not the right choice that being said I
understand and empathize with his
children I mean you could also consider
that this doctor isn't a doctor right
like we don't know who this guy is who
claims to be a doctor let me see your
credentials
and you're like yeah I was a brain
surgeon and they're like prove it and
you just take a body and go and they're
like I guess that's what brain surgery
looks like I don't know it's like I'm
actually a man that owns a deli
I was a deli surgeon I was wondering
I'm a ham surgeon now are you familiar
with the idea I do thin slices
um uh because and again like even if
this guy is a real brain surgeon and
cuts it out but like this might not even
work right it might not even work uh but
but yes who do you think Joel did it for
do you think Joel did for Ellie or for
him or four I don't know he did it for
himself it was clearly it has to be
himself he's not saving Ellie he loves
her yeah like she was the one that was
like I need to do this I need to do this
and he's like
um well I can't let that slide you're
all I have I think he's justified in
saying like she didn't get a choice and
if you give another choice I could maybe
abide bye even if Marley was like oh he
asked her because the tape recording for
saying it's okay Joel would have still
made like um
I think that well well if I was in his
shoes honestly my biggest concern would
be the consent part of it right but one
I don't think he cares because one he
didn't stick around to wait until she
woke up right right hey just to make
sure you okay all right go back to sleep
and two I think the reason he tells her
that they stopped looking for a cure is
because he knows that she would go back
if she if she didn't want to know she
didn't have the choice yeah I don't
think he actually cares about that
aspect I think this is completely
selfish well that's just for a human
well that's part of the second thing
right if we all kind of agree Ellie
doesn't buy it at all right oh he's not
buying it no so in theory she could
immediately be like screw you I know
you're lying I'm going back but she's
not going to because I think
she also wants to live because she does
have a reason to live she's found of the
family that she's so desperate for her
biggest fear was being alone and this
man this man would do whatever it takes
to be with her and she's not gonna
there's no what's the point of living
yeah in a world that's fine if if you
don't even have that and I think that's
totally justified the do you think La
believed the lie I would say
yes and when I say yes it's a long
answer
that's a long answer I think it's more
so it's like this is the only person you
can trust in the entire world right now
period Tommy's gone like I guess you can
go back to time you didn't even like
Tommy's wife like it's all she knows is
Joel right and I think you're right when
it's like this guy's protecting me this
guy is like I'm following him he's
definitely my father figure but I think
she still knows that he's lying but
she's like
I'm not going it's it's a weird I don't
know there's probably a word for it to
be like I'm not gonna go against what
you said like I trust you so much that
I'm trying to believe you but I know
you're lying to me but it's that it's
still him it's still Joel it's her dad
so it's like I think she I think she
knows he's lying but I don't think she
is this is this the prisoner's dilemma
where Joel knows that she knows he's
lying but but as long as they have this
this kind of fake agreement on the
outside yeah they can move forward
there's gonna be a time in the second
season where someone's gonna be like do
you believe him and be like she's going
back now she's gonna I mean that's only
possible Right someone from the outside
ass should be like oh no this guy killed
them no he did it I think she
desperately desperately wants it to be
true but deep deep down she has doubts
for sure I to relate it
there was one time where I had to get
shots right two shots for college
you went to liquor I went to photo shoot
needles and I had to get it at like a
grocery store which sucked and so I was
sitting and the dude the produce
department was this the deli doctor
she's like looking I didn't wash my
hands after stuffing this turkey I woke
up with Jesus in my pocket
with party stuck out of your body it
wasn't a needle needle as a toothbrush
no listen there's no story I got the
first shot and then he was like okay up
up I gotta turn the chair around and get
the other arm and I was like and I got
up and I sat back down and then he was
about to get the second shot I was like
I feel really [__] busy and I pass
out and then I come to and when I come
to he's like all right well you're gonna
have to come back tomorrow to get your
second shot and I was like why didn't
you give it to me when I was passed out
like I hate needles and so with Ellie
it's kind of like I would I would think
that like oh my God you should have
killed me when I didn't know I was gonna
be killed now that I'm alive yeah like
I mean my thing with like you know with
all these zombie shows like
post-apocalyptics everyone's like what
what's your plan my plans to [__] die
immediately yeah oh yeah I do not want
to live in this post-apocalyptic world
and that's an interesting idea you bring
up Anna the idea that like now that she
has been taken out of this this kind of
clean option of like just going to sleep
and not knowing what happened now she's
forced to be here it's like well I
better make
some sort of tacit agreement with my
reality that like oh everything's fine
because because I don't want to take the
option of like it would be really scary
going back to space yeah I mean also
even if she went back for all she knows
everyone's dead the doctor's dead like
no one else can necessarily do the
operation now I'm sure the two nurses
that survived are gonna tell the rest of
the fireflies about what happened I
don't know what's gonna happen kill that
Joel and that Elliot well we got lots
more to talk about with this episode uh
but first we want to thank our sponsors
for today including quip over the past
couple of weeks our friends equip asked
you yes you to vote for your favorite
Last of Us character Joel or Ellie
whichever character received the most
votes from the promo codes Joel or Ellie
would be crowned the quipocalypse winner
would be sending a special power up to
everyone who made a qualifying purchase
using the Winner's code and the votes
are in folks the quipocalypse winner is
Joe that's why that's why we're dressed
like this which is in 30 minutes into
this episode I get that and you probably
were very confused at why I look like we
waited a little too long no no I think
it was worth it can you explain which
direction
are you my first episode Joel okay and
I'm last uh Joel episode eight who's
under the blanket and it's totally has
to kill ready
[Music]
it's my hydro bag I I sold my pills but
I could still eat the residue is it
Pedro's hair kind of quaffed up like
neatly no Pedro's hair looks like this
oh okay I'm Pedro from the Mandalorian
roughed up oh okay okay this is this has
been my contribution I appreciate it
thanks Dill thank you thank you to all
the drills and thank you to you so if
you look out be on the lookout for an
email from quip sooner than later if you
voted for Joel and if you missed the
contest no worries just go to
getquip.com new rockstars and you'll get
20 off and equip water flosser equipped
toothbrush or equip um starter kit their
electric toothbrush is great as a Time
Sonic vibrations with 30 second pulses
uh to get a dentist recommended two
minute clean there's no wires or bulky
charging to weigh you down uh don't they
have this really awesome uh water
flosser that blasts away plaque and
popcorn with Precision thanks to the 360
degree rotating magnet floss tip that
snaps into place and boy this thing has
got some let me hold it up let me hold
it up
foreign
don't worry and there's also sugar-free
gum it helps prevent cavities and fresh
your breath with when you chew it for 20
minutes or you chew it for 20 minutes
after eating this is great sugar-free
clean your breath clear it all up the
first season of The Last of Us might be
over but the fight to against tooth
decay never ends folks grip wants to
know what is the one item you would need
for the apocalypse just tag me rockstars
and quip in your Instagram post and show
us what you would need for the
apocalypse keep it clean keep it clean
maybe take your water flosser defend off
the cordyceps you saw what it could do
to a human eye imagine what it could do
infected persons you could clear your
eyes with it the fungus girls do not
keep this in your eyes absolutely choose
something it's a tongue scraper oh okay
because I'm a person that cares about my
dental hygiene tongue snipers are great
because yeah it gets all that big and
all that stuff uh you can be featured on
our pages so make sure you are following
And subscribe uh to both new rhinestars
and quip also head on over to
getquip.com new rockstars right now
right now to get 20 off uh to get 20 off
any clip water flosser grip toothbrush
or quips gum starter kit that's
g-e-t-quip.com new rockstars go to Turbo
Tax and don't do your taxes meet with an
expert who'll do them for you Turbo Tax
experts can relieve you from the stress
of taxes and file for you so you can do
not taxes show your eyes things that are
not taxes unpack a moving box of not
taxes taste not taxes seeing not tax is
a lullaby hope not taxes sleep through
the night grab a saddle and ride not
taxes into the sunset with Turbo Tax an
expert will do your taxes from start to
finish ensuring your taxes are done
right guaranteed so you can relax feels
good to be done with your taxes doesn't
it come to Turbo Tax and don't do your
taxes visit turbotax.com to learn more
Intuit TurboTax full service products
only video meeting while expert does
your taxes required see guaranteed
details at turbotax.com guaranteed so my
second question for you both today how
did you take the explanation of Ellie's
immunity did we even need an explanation
in the show this is something that was
new from the game right they didn't
really get into this in the game uh as
far as like where her immunity come from
oh so I'm completely wrong about it are
you talking about like how it the core
steps are in the brain what well showing
the moment that essentially created the
immunity for it yeah and I think that
was probably the best way to do is by
introducing her mom right doing doing
the entire thing with her mom I it made
us realize like also the knife like
seeing the actual knife that comes back
but just like feeling that moment for
Anna and then seeing how much she is
actually like Ellie right was so nice
for storytelling purposes but also it
really needed for understanding how
Ellie is immune I mean we did joke about
it like video game players which is kind
of running through the woods might
recognize some of the like like grunts
the Ellie grunts you would get in the
game yeah you know what I mean yeah the
voice was very familiar very familiar it
took me a minute because I'm an idiot I
was like that's Ashley Johnson right it
wasn't because her eyes was so dark yeah
her hair was so dark one thing that did
kind of concern me was that
Marlene would know pretty much now how
the immunity got passed on Ellie so it's
like is there now going to be like a
farm where people are born
hoping but I genuinely think Marlene
believes that she cut the umbilical cord
before it happens and that's honestly
I'm not to be a person
stupid thing I would be like let's try
maybe well I think Marlene needs to
think that to keep this baby alive yeah
to keep the other people who have seen
yes that's true and I also you know we
kind of talked about why you we joked
about Marlene throwing her into a
federal school I think it was just to
keep her away from the fireflies because
the fireflies were dangerous they're
deemed as a terrorist group by these
like fascist overlords so if if they're
ever caught this baby would be either
killed or wind up at a federal school
anyways so I think her thinking is like
I gotta keep it away from this dangerous
Society but I'll keep an eye on her from
afar but I liked
yeah
one small thing they changed that I
don't know it's not I'm really a spoiler
um is that instead of saying it grows
inside the brain it like they did in the
show in the game they say around or on
the brain right um and I think inside
the in the brain makes it a little more
like um
well it's like I I if I'm if I'm correct
in my medicine and I did go to a deli
school
um uh rabies grows like in the brain and
the only way to test an animal for
rabies is to like basically after it's
dead check its brain stem uh and I think
it's like the same for humans if if you
if you get bit by an animal and they
think you have rabies they just give you
rabies shots because they can't really
like test for it very well uh check with
your local Deli guy to make sure that's
true
um just don't get two shots in a row
don't get two shots in a row uh uh but
yeah this idea that like there's no way
to get this out of her without killing
her so we'll put it fully inside her
brain yeah so that you as the audience
know like this had to happen
um I did I did like this kind of
explanation for immunity and again we're
thinking this is how it happened there
was no like I'm Mr scientist and this is
exactly how it happened yeah you see
these events unfold and it makes a lot
of sense it was like this is how it
could be the most believable option they
could do like was it uh airtight yeah a
big questions about like the timing
between the bite and kind
which it probably does and by not like
changing you fully but if it moves
through your bloodstream that quickly it
could make it and then in a weird gross
way if it's in the vaginal Canal she
could have gone through the secretions
on her way out I know a lot about sex
yeah because like when a baby goes
through like the birth canal right it's
yeah stuff is put on the baby uh to like
make it more immune to diseases and
stuff when it comes out of the womb and
normally the baby would develop its own
blood cells and do all its other things
eventually as it creates its own but
when it's first born it doesn't but then
again it's a cordyce we don't know what
that yeah it's like a perfect
combination of this woman is pregnant
she's full of like extra hormones
because of the pregnancy that are being
fed to the baby she has the extra she
gets bit at the right moment and also
yes there could be some genetic makeup
about this person that all of these
things combined this is the baby that is
most like
what we saw is what it is the immune
there is definitely other immune babies
out there I mean that there has to be
like another person yeah I guarantee it
like there's other immune babies and I
think your idea which also my wife I
think immediately had of like let's get
a farm going where yeah he's getting bit
all the time like that's like if this
was the X-Files That season none of the
last of us right we discovered the farm
of all these pregnant women
just like tied up but technically you'd
only have to do that 10
can have immune babies Theory we don't
know how it works but I think you also
you just cut open the baby and get the
brain right you do what you're gonna do
damn that's dark as hell that's the
boy's [__] the boys would do that
couldn't open baby's heads oh god oh my
god let's go to the game changes take it
away
well just gotta shake that off yeah
Green all right we're back baby this
section is where we talk about the game
versus the show I know
before but this is the real this is the
real if you want to go into the game
blind do not watch this section we're
talking about it not part two yeah no
part two game
um so we never see Anna in the games uh
that is completely new to the show we
hear her name through Marlene's voice
recordings and stuff like that but the
whole intro with the giving birth the
explanation for Ally's immunity is new
uh Ellie gets the knife as a baby for
Marlene or like you know Marlene passes
it along down the generations uh but a
fun fact in the comic she gets it as a
teenager
uh something that I was kind
of kind of changed about this is that
one of my favorite parts of the game is
that when we cut to right after she does
the staff stop stabby Steppy with David
and it cuts to Springtime they are on
that Highway her and Joel but in the
game Ellie is staring and disassociating
at um like a car kind of a carving a
plaque of a deer on them and I love the
symbolism of this because it's just such
a moment where you can see the absolute
loss of Innocence that came from that
chapter
um because I said this in a trailer
breakdown deers often represent
innocence she has that moment where she
kills the deer right before all the day
of the stuff goes down and so I really
wish they had CGI the freaking deer
plaque onto a wall come on sorry anyway
next time oh you still get the
disassociating moment so fine
um Jules attempt to take his own life is
also a New Concept to the show and
heartbreaking one holy crap I think
flying emotional line of the episode was
her saying I'm glad that didn't
um some game players had there's there's
a idea that maybe he did this between
game players but that mostly has to do
towards his attitude around the subject
yeah but
they never at least say that he
attempted anything like that
um in the game and there's a whole
section where they're going through a
tunnel and then the tunnel's filled with
water Ellie can't swim
yeah so okay well strange
um but in the game this moment where
they get knocked out results from them
going down a flooded tunnel like hopping
cars Joel gets taken under and then
Ellie follows him and then they
basically pass out from being underwater
too long and then they wake up to the
fireflies pointing guns at them or well
Ellie doesn't wake up it only sent two
the fireflies point he gets of them
um and yeah in the in the show there's
just a flash thing which is much more
effective much more effective yeah
quicker uh the explanation the infection
is new also the surgery process like I
said inside versus around or on or
whatever something I noticed which
seemed like a weird change to me but I
noticed it was very specific when
Marlene is talking about what the result
of the surgery is going to be in the
game she says they could make a vaccine
Joel of vaccine and in the show they
changed it to a cure doll a cure that's
gotta be a panda it's like a vaccine's a
very charged word and they're like they
don't want to get demonetized on YouTube
I also think vaccine and cure are two
different yeah you define them are very
different actually it's not 100 but it
cures 100 so they probably in the game
were like yeah what you gonna do and
then now they're like oh wait a minute
wait a minute hold on they know what a
vaccine is now uh in the show a new
aspect is when Joel walks away you see a
single tear roll down Marlene's face you
see this is really affecting her in the
game because we have to follow Joel and
Ellie you don't see this but you do get
a taste of how much she like regrets is
how hard this has been through tape
recordings and journals that she leaves
and things like that
um in the show well in the game uh the
guy that there's only one guy that
ushers Joel out of the room and shoves
him with the gun a couple times and in
order to get the info of where Ellie is
out of him Joel shoots him in the gut a
couple times to get that info and he
finally admits like torches him and he
admits that she's in the Pediatric Ward
uh and then Joel kills him in the show
he doesn't have any of that he's
literally like I don't have time for
this
I ain't got time it's all about
efficiency in the show they just gotta
go pick it up you know
um in the show Joel like how Joel lies
to Ellie is a little bit it's like
lengthened he doesn't go into Raiders
attacking the hospital
um he doesn't go into any of that it's
it's very kind of brief in the game a
lot of the lines are the same but the
thing about the Raiders attacking that's
that's new oh okay um her also asking if
Marlene's okay is new in the show but I
think that Subs out in the game her
relationship already being developed
with Marlene like you know that she
likes her so in the show they had to
replace that with dialogue instead so
that makes sense
um the the ending is nearly Shopper shot
they go into more detail in their
conversations about Sarah that
conversation's a little longer
um and the final conversation with Joel
and Ellie where Ellie talks about all
the people that have died
his all he says in return is something
like he's like I know what survival
survivor's guilt is like and then she
has the last moment in in the show he
goes on and on about like I don't know
something where she's like no no no
that's not what I'm saying or whatever
um and then finally a big one is that in
the show we have confirmation that she
had to kill Riley which we never got in
the game that's a big deal it's a big
deal this is her person she hurt I would
assume yeah that reference she made uh
she straight up said killed she didn't
even say hurt this time she didn't use
the euphemism the good speak if you will
uh going through our kill counts real
quick Ellie coming in with one kill uh
posthumously uh she killed Riley in the
past we'll give her the point this time
uh Joel having a murderer's row of 18.
going through the hospital sorry doc
Marlene they also sorry just interject
they've been talking druckman and Neil
and their podcast have been talking
about how much they wanted to have those
people who were killed personified when
they held on that guy's face for yeah
yeah quite a while I feel like that was
these are not just like generic baddies
these are people they use dreams a lot
they've given a lot of names
usually you think if you get a name as
an actor you'll probably live but now
I'm sure
Marlene came in with a kill
um began and then Anna coming in with a
killer self being the uh uh infected
that person into the house before I wrap
everything up today we'll get into some
full spoiler talk now so if you don't
want to be spoiled about season two get
out of here uh be a major antagonist for
The Last of Us Part Two is a girl named
Abby her dad Jerry was the doctor that
Joel shoots at the end we learned in the
second game that Marlene also didn't
want Ali to die and fought Jerry on the
procedure but eventually relented
because if it's secure to cure folks we
also know that Abby was in the hospital
that night and finds his body after
Joel's rampage this is all revealed in
the second game I mentioned this because
one of the nurses in the hospital is
played by Laura Bailey that's my girl
the voice actress that played Abby in
the game and I saw cameo in reference
for her uh I think it's also worth
pointing out that really the only setup
for season two is the camera holding on
Jerry's head wound for a while before
Joel Scoops up Ellie kind of emphasizing
this guy died this guy's really
surprised at that yeah he didn't have
any attitude I also love it's very
similar I mean in the game you have to
pull the trigger on the doctor like a
very intense kind of moment and I don't
know when when I played it I kind of
took a second because I was like do I
not do this I don't understand I like
how the show is just like nope yeah like
I'm not taking I don't want to hear your
pitch I don't want to hear you down I
have not played the second game period
uh because I didn't want to spoil the
first season for me right right and when
my mom watched every spoiler of his
things he has told me everything she
keeps being like Oh my God they didn't
even care about the doctor they were
like she didn't she was like why don't
they care about the doctor did I know
Abby yet and I was like no no one knows
everyone knows Abby no one no one knows
Abby yeah my mom is also speculating
earlier that we saw Abby
times I think what we were also talking
about in Tommy's place but uh I guess it
gives the new audience the same
experiences the game players got but I'm
just surprised there's there's no link
because in when they were making the
first game druckman didn't know that
Abby was going to be the doctors he
didn't know he'd get a second game he
had no idea um but they did know that
when making this show I don't I'm just
there's there's a shock we do know the
show's getting a second season very
exciting I can't wait to see what they
do in it uh I think they had a very
successful first season they already
knew really great adaptation of the
video game I'm really excited to see
where this show goes and I can't believe
it's over so quickly I know I needed
this for my health I wasn't feeling
great watching the show but I really
couldn't do it for your help if you're
feeling down go talk to your jelly
doctor today and see what's he can slice
off of your body it'll make you feel
better don't get within three feet of
him
keep the distance between the glass
where the meat is shown in him okay that
is it for this episode of the break room
although the last of us has finished it
filming we do do this show this show
right here not this show exactly but the
break room right every day live at 3 P.M
you also get the Mandalorian The Wookie
leads
coverage on the break room so check that
out on Wednesday mornings uh yeah filthy
freaks yeah filthy Mando freaks you
Wookie League says Tommy calls you
follow me at Lulu underscore Clemens
follow Brandon at grin and Barrick
follow Anna at it's Anna vanston
she pulled it from behind my ear she's I
didn't know Joel was a magician but I
guess he is today subscribe to the break
room wherever you get your podcast and
we'll see you again next Tuesday thanks
for watching endurance survives
[Music]
foreign